then when they can find anything that
you say that could without further
explanation or definition be
misconstrued as appealing to this
definition of you like for instance when
all this when this what I guess they
call themselves in cells involuntary
celibates when all this stuff went down
this car drove his car into a group of
people it's horrible tragedy one of the
things that you talked about within
cells is that and this was a part of the
Rome what was it there's a New York
Times timepiece yeah you you said one of
the cures for this is enforced monogamy
people decided and you know I had never
heard that term before quite honestly
and that was like what the [ __ ] does
that mean it's a psychological term and
what it means is enforced by culture
that it is a good value monogamy yeah
because polygamous societies tend to
become ultra violent yeah and that's
been known in the anthropological
literature for a hundred years and and
certainly leftist anthropologists were
among those who discovered it like she
knew the journalists knew perfectly well
what I meant by enforcement Olga be she
was stupid
it's a you use it as if everybody would
understand it because you're an
intellectual and because you're a
professor in this also two minutes out
of a two-day conversation you know it's
like so if that socially just glanced oh
well it's so fun that was funny in some
sense because my sense is if you want a
pillory someone you should attribute to
them views that someone somewhere has
had and the implication of that part of
the New York Times article was that I
wanted to you know take nubile young
women at the point of a gun under state
enforcement and deliver them useless men
it's like no one has ever believed that
so trading sounds like yeah it's a
really the optics of that that statement
are very bad but the question is why
didn't why wasn't there follow-up
questions and if there was follow-up
questions to get you to define what you
mean by enforcement not well there were
they just didn't make it into the piece
that's a real problem yeah it's a real
problem that's a real problem because
that's that that is it's so ridiculous
because inaccurate definition of who you
are one of the things I've said
continually I'm and this is on record in
multiple places it's like okay so you're
a young man
hmm and all the women are rejecting you
who's got the problem it's not all the
women that's a bad road to go down if
all the women are rejecting you it's you
we both agree on this but why is
enforced monogamy the solution for
people that are involuntary celibates
well it's the solution to them it's the
solution to the relationship between men
and women fundamentally is monogamous
social norm men are unattractive if
these were suggestion to them but if
these men are unattractive to women I
don't mean just physically unattractive
mean women aren't seeking them as mates
mhm they need to become men yes they
certainly do so to this illusion that's
the solution absolute and we both agree
on this yes what they need to do that in
this society where monogamy is the
social norm but isn't a social norm
anyway well that was partly my point
although to the degree that we deviate
from that we tilt towards a more violent
society I was making a very minor point
I don't think they're related quite
honestly I know I don't think that
involuntary celibates I don't think that
having enforced monogamy as a part of
our cultural norm is gonna help those
people
it does how's it gonna help them well
because what happens is if a polygamous
society develops which is the
alternative then a small minority of men
get all the women that's what happens
okay that's the only point which may
fear Allah theoretical world where
polygamous societies exist and mass and
then you do have this problem with this
a small group of men that are [ __ ]
all the women but that's not what we're
talking and also making the women
unhappy right because the women don't
have any access to a genuine intimate
one-to-one relationship over any long
period of time which doesn't work well
nah it's the whole idea so much best
women want that right sure if you have
children right but I still don't think
that that is why these men are
involuntary celibates and I don't think
it's the solution to that I think the
solution is that they need to become
attractive yes that is the solution
I don't think the two are related well
the only I was making a minor point the
minor point was that one of the ways
that societies around the world have
figured out that you keep young male
aggression under control is by enforcing
monogamous standards because it gives
everyone a chance in some sense the only
chance meaning it clears more more women
will be available for one-on-one
relationships rather than one guy who is
some you know whatever for whatever
reason so what you see in society well
you see this happening in universities
where women outnumber men so the man
hypothetically have more sexual
opportunity but that isn't what happens
what happens is that a small minority of
men have all the sexual opportunity a
fairly large minority of men don't the
women are on how because they can't find
a committed relationship it's bad for
most of the men and the men who have all
the sexual opportunity gets cynical but
isn't this in some ways against your
whole idea of equality of outcome
because you're talking about equality of
sexual outcome now if these men James
that's the dominant basketball player
that just kicks everyone's ass this is
the this this is a guy who's succeeded
at the highest level right well there's
going to be people like that sexually
there's going to be people that are
better at finding mates and that this is
what they enjoy they enjoy having many
mates enjoy being yes but but if this is
what they enjoy if it's a man who
doesn't want a family and enjoys dating
multiple women why is that bad well the
I think the fundamental reason it's bad
is because it's bad in the long run for
children it's bad for children if he
chooses to have children fundamental
issue as far as I'm concerned right and
I think it's the answer look to give the
journalist credit that is the point she
was making you know apart from pillory
me and and and and caricature in my
perspective that was the point she was
making well first of all I'm not in
favor of unbridled hierarchies I've
already said that you know the
proclivity of a hierarchy is that
they're all the spoils go to the person
at the top right and that can
destabilize the whole straw
yes so we have to have a dialogue about
how to rectify that but how did you
possibly rectify that if one man is but
like say if we've got one six foot five
beautiful man who's got a perfect body
and yet brilliant and he just wants to
date a bunch of women yeah and all the
rest of the people are five foot one and
they're fat and they're lazy and like
this guy's gonna if this is the
competition he's going to win yep yep
there's no way around this and yet even
ones decide to have enforced monogamy
where it becomes a popular thing the
women are gonna be more drawn to him if
he chooses to date them they might
decide I would rather have him sometimes
than never is that actually what does
happen but what is wrong with that well
what's wrong with it is that it
destabilized the society and it's bad
for children right you said that yeah
but that's what if they don't want to
have children but there's a lot of
people that don't want to have children
there's a lot of people that choose to
go their entire life without having
children this men in their 30s some of
my friends have vasectomies they don't
want children
mm-hmm so why why would that help in any
way these involuntary celibates well I
think you tilt the society so that it
serves the interests of well that's a
good question to you but you see my
point I see your point
no doubt about it you're almost having
you're almost forcing and in an equality
of outcome no that would not was her
point to him to the degree that she had
a point that was her point now and but I
but it's not who doesn't run contrary to
my opinions that the issue of outcome
has to be addressed I already said
there's needs to be a reason for the
left and the right and then the problem
with hierarchies is they can get too
steep and destabilize everything that
does happen that particularly happens in
the sexual domain and there's plenty of
anthropological evidence for that but
you still might say well who cares
because the men who are who are winning
should be allowed to win and the women
should be allowed to choose it's like
yes except that there's the problem of
children and so society steps in on
behalf of the children and you can say
well lots of people don't want to have
children yes and that's truer now than
it used to be although many of those
people end up having children anyways
you know the guys
around all the time so that doesn't
circumvent the problem but the issue
here for me isn't the men or the women
it's the children we're trying to set up
societies where the probability that
children will be raised in something
approximated an optimal environment is
optimized and that's going to mean
sacrifice of opportunity and choice on
the part of adults it's necessary I
agree with you but I think that what
we're talking about mirrors what we're
talking about in sports it mirrors what
we're talking about in business it's
everything else there's going to be
people that are better at all different
aspects of life there's going to be
people that are talented in terms of
like getting women to like them yes
that's true well that's why I also look
you see this right women are high
Pergamus which means they mate up in a
crew they meet across an OP dominance
hierarchies and so if you're a male
who's successful in a given hierarchy
the probability that you're gonna have
additional mating opportunities is
exceptionally high it's an unbelievably
good predictor of that that hypergamy is
a very uncomfortable discussion yes I'm
certainly it doesn't matter well there's
plenty of inaudible discussions too
that's a big one though it is the idea
that it defines women's sexual choices
by the fact that they want begger bigger
better someone who's more more
successful someone who's so higher on
the social ladder than what they're
accustomed to are what they yeah well
what women do is like mate choice is a
very difficult problem so how do you
solve it well here's how women solve it
throw the man in a ring let them compete
at whatever they're competing at assume
that the man who wins is the best man
marry him yes it's a brilliant solution
it's a market-oriented solution it's
actually the solution that appears to
have driven our evolutionary departure
from chimpanzees it's a biological
solution and it's a logical solution
which will cost what is the cost well
the cost is the cost is polygamy
and so we rein that in with enforced
monogamy and we do that in order to
provide stable stable circumstances for
children is polyamorous is a polyamorous
society just as unattainable as this
utopian Marxist yes yeah I think so
because it looks like this is another
point I was making that didn't get
covered in the in in the article or the
wrote about it somewhat extensively on
my blog is that society's tilt towards
monogamy across the world is human
Universal now that doesn't mean that
people don't have polygamists or
polyamorous tendencies because they
certainly do and it's certainly also the
case that one of the women ways that
women gerrymander this system is that
like the number of women children who
are in a say say you're married and you
have children with your husband but you
also have an affair so we have a child
by another man that's more common than
anyone suspected so part of the way that
women solve the problem that you're just
describing and I'm not saying anything
for this or against this this is a
purely factual biological claim is they
pick a monogamous marriage and they
cheat with high status guys now you know
obviously in the confines of the
marriage that's a terrible thing but
that's a very uncomfortable subject
though for women in particular
uncomfortable subject for everyone right
but it's a curse to all subject they
don't like the idea that this is a
common thing that women choose a safe
man that is willing to be monogamous
with them and perhaps maybe they're
above him in a social class or in
sexually and then they'll cheat with
someone who's it's common but it's not
the norm
right it's still the norm not to do that
the norm is fidelity right but but
there's plenty of exception this is
enforced monogamy Coulson or monogamy is
this it's like okay so my sons getting
married in in September and so so let's
say he comes to me in the year and he
says hey Dad guess what I've had three
affairs in the last year and they've all
been successful I haven't got caught
aren't ia good guy what am I gonna say
to that no what the hell are you doing
that's not what you're supposed to be
doing that's enforced monogamy
enforcement aagama meaning the
around you try to guide them in a way
that you think is gonna yes it's
harmonious family
yes it's built deep into the cultural
norms and if that starts to destabilize
then there's trouble and that doesn't
mean that it's not prone to all the
problems that you laid out look there
isn't a bigger problem than successful
reproduction it is the big problem and
all of the solutions that we've
generated for it are full of flaws like
here's an example the gender pay gap
okay there's no gender pay gap there's a
mother gap there's other reasons too but
women really take a hit when they become
mothers okay that's unfair fair enough
man what the hell are you gonna do about
it's not just